ich hab mir jetzt vorgenommen mal
zwischendurch was zu trinken in meinen
videos damit ich auch nicht so viele
sprachfehler mache
hey was geht ab netz willkommen bei
einem neuen video hier mal wieder auf
einem kanal und so ja ich habe immer
wieder hat natürlich ganz cooles 1
verlassen
und zwar geht es halt einfach mal um
dinge die nur ich tue da gibt es ein
paar die irgendwie relativ komisch und
die will ich euch einfach mal vorstellen
ich wünsch euch gaaanz viel spaß mit dem
video wollen jetzt auch direkt mal
anfang und irgendeine nummer eins ja ich
habe keine ahnung warum ich das mache es
ist praktisch wieder ein reflex auf
jeden fall wenn ich von irgendwo nach
hause komme und mein fahrrad in die
garage stellen dann schließlich
irgendwie ab und wundere mich am
nächsten tagen abgeschlossen habe und
findet den schlüssel dann nicht hätten
das jetzt abgeschlossen
und überhaupt mein schlüssel und dann
kommt auch schon zu nummer zwei und zwar
ist das so also irgendwie immer wenn ich
meine haare mache ich tu dir wachs rein
dann dann verwische ich das so extra
nochmal dem handtuch also wenn ihr das
gleich seht ihr werdet euch denn ich mal
denken ist der junge irgendwie gestört
oder warum macht er dann ich habe das
irgendwie so für mich rausgefunden meine
haare stehen dann besser weil dieses
relativ dünn sind aber sonst habe ich
auch keine ahnung warum ich das mache
und wenn ich mal so genau darüber
nachdenke dann weiß ich auch irgendwie
überhaupt nicht wie jetzt genau darauf
gekommen wenn meine haare irgendwie nach
dem hochseil handtuch zu rubbeln
da und dann kommen wir jetzt auch schon
diese diese filme hier könnt ihr die
wenn ihr so kümmel an den police hat die
so richtig nerven
auf jeden fall kommen wir jetzt auch
schon kommen wir jetzt auch dann schon
zur nummer drei und zwar weiß ich ihr
könnt aber bestimmt so apfelmus
apfelkompott keine ahnung wie er das
nennt auf jeden fall es oder ist man das
ja ganz gerne mal zu kaiserschmarrn oder
zufall kuchen aber ich es dass natürlich
auch richtig gerne zu pizza und dazu
cheeseburger das schmeckt mir einfach
extrem gut ich weiß ich bin so seitdem
ihr kleiner essig cheeseburger oder
pizza mit apfelkompott und ja wisst ihr
auch auf jeden fall mal ausprobieren
erschreckt
und zum schluss noch eine sache die ich
mir so für morgens vor der schule
aufstehen angewöhnt habe ich stehe es
aufgeht dann nach unten frühstücke ich
das dauert so fünf minuten dann bin ich
wieder oben
dann lege ich mich ins bett rein guckt
noch ein bisschen am handy pendant
irgendwie so halt wieder ein und
vergesst total die zeit und kommen dann
auch ab und zu mal zu spät wieder aus
dem bett und muss wieder relativ bei uns
das auch irgendwie sonne behinderte
angewohnheit von mir die ich irgendwie
vielleicht mehr abstellen sollte aber
keine ahnung ist ja im endeffekt auch
nur schule hätte schon zu spät
so leute und das wasser doch leider
schon wieder mit diesem video ich hoffe
natürlich es hat euch immer gefallen und
er gibt leicht nach oben
wenn es euch nicht ganz so gefallen hat
dann geht das wurde dann geht natürlich
auch einfach einen daumen nach oben
und wenn ihr nichts mehr verpassen wollt
abonniert einfach den kanal ansonsten
check doch meine beschreibung für
instagram facebook und co könnt ihr mir
folgt wenn ihr volk ab und irgendwie
ansonsten jetzt hier unten rechts noch
weiter mit meinem letzten video das war
der boyfriend tag 2 mit meiner freundin
und hier unten links mit meinem
vorletzten video was sagen wir da mal
hier war mein neues konzept every second
können die aber beides abdecken also
vorbeischauen und wir sehen uns nächste
woche
nächstes wochenende wieder ich wünsche
euch sonst nur und traumhaftes
wochenende hatte ein